good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday i hope
everyone's having an amazing day
so far so good i mean really i can't
complain no not for me
but like oh i can complain but like we
said like tuesday is really like a
sleeper day of the week that
really sucks it does like it's just so
it's nowhere yeah it's taken us nowhere
we've gotten nowhere
but these days tuesday is more exciting
because we're doing gear toasters on a
tuesday yes oh i forgot this is our
first week we've like gotten kind of
crazy over here changing things up we
used to do deer toasters on wednesday
now we do it on tuesdays so get ready
for it watch out world and watch out we
didn't do your toasters last week so we
have a lot of advice to give
um i did while you were on vacation oh
really don't downplay my hard work me
and tyler i saw a comment where's your
toasters
with tyler say like me and tyler c
dished out advice
he was being very kind it was actually
similar dynamic
oh really because you're usually like
nice and i'm do you think so
my brand of advice is tough love
like that's me yeah maybe okay whatever
he was being really kind and generous
and i was just more like cut that toxic
[ __ ] out yeah it was a really good
balance of different energies yeah like
whatever advice you were actually
looking for
you could probably find right somewhere
in the middle between me and tyler like
he was too nice i'm like tyler i think
people are walking all over you
are you worried about him also no
tonight's the night i'm so excited for
him tyler on watch robin's live with
luann de la sap oh my god so rony's on
tonight
i don't know i've read somewhere real
housewives of beverly hills is not on
this week
i wish every tv show would just pause
because i'm so invested in the olympics
i was literally watching
japan versus oh no china vs brazil this
morning in beach volleyball like i watch
anything you know
and that's kind of where my priorities
are and all these shows like love island
i know big brother's on right now
i really just can't balance it i'm
feeling very underwater
you know yeah no it is a little
disrespectful
disrespectful for love island like the
show is never on and
the two weeks that is on is the same as
the olympics no it's just a show that
you need to watch every single night but
i
am all caught up and this is not a
spoiler but
because you're one thousand episodes
behind i'm very behind i'm going to
catch up
but i will allow you to spoil it for me
no i'm not going to spoil anything but
we casa a more happened
what do you think and it's really
bothering me like i feel very protective
over these girls the ogs
yeah and now there's a big ceremony and
everyone left
no i won't spoil that for you okay um so
it's just like really bothering me not
seeing the new girls
no not seeing the old girls in casa amor
with new guys but seeing
the old guys with new girls right who
are so disrespectful like
literally there was this girl i just
hated her from the second she started
because when she was just giving me bad
energy
and two like when the girls knew they
were leaving for casa and more and the
boys were out of the house they all like
left cute little things in their
boyfriend's cubbies you know
and kira even though i don't like her
she's so lame
she like left this note with lipstick on
will's mirror and a kiss
and the girls the new girls got to the
house before the guys got back and they
wiped off her message it was like so
rude this one girl did it and she was
like
bye and i'm like you are doing too much
like we don't know you yet like you're
now a villain in my eyes i know but
those girls have to come in so hot
because they need to make a splash
one like they need to be memorable if
they're not going to move on
forward like you know this is a job
they're on tv and two like they're they
are trying to steal someone's man and
get a spot in the house it's
it's cut through there's a girl who
knows shannon she's like i'm really good
friends with shannon's little sister and
like i think josh is hot
josh didn't even look at her like that
is so crazy isn't casa anymore it's just
it's really actually annoying me because
first of all i just learned everyone's
names and now i have 10 more people
whose names i need to remember but you
won't need to remember them because act
like you know hopefully because
eventually there's only so many beds in
the main house
a lot of people have to go home it makes
me feel weird yeah casa more anything
can happen in casa moore
so true so true um i was just gonna say
one more thing about
love island but now i can no longer
recall
well you have to get all caught up so we
could do a proper recap but i'm just
once again i feel like i say the same
thing
every time we recap the show loving
being a part of something yes
oh this is what i was going to say did
you hear this rumor and i only saw it
once and i didn't look into it at all so
maybe it's not a thing
that will and kira were dating before
the show
no i saw i don't know where i saw it
where'd you see it
i don't someone like commented maybe on
like one of our things like that that is
what's
i mean it's definitely believable
because
they're so weird and like hot and heavy
and they both like just happen to be
interested in like the same things like
meditation you know
yeah so just keep your eye out for that
that would be crazy a true
shocker yeah but i mean whatever they're
pretty irrelevant i mean who knows what
happens now but so
irrelevant you know it's like bachelor
in paradise once you're like all loved
up it's like you go into your
yeah and there's something just like not
even cute about them because i could
argue that shannon and josh are like
just as coupled up
not as they're actually like a little
less but they're not boring at all like
i
die for them yeah i agree they're just
too boring people agreed
like all they do is yoga and like make
smoothies and eggs and kiss
all the time um okay so that was like
our unofficial
love island recap but um we're gonna get
back into the tv recaps this week
yes this is this is what we were talking
about right we started
um we'll see what's on this week but i'm
really just like i said proud american
yeah exactly we have some olympics news
to cover which is just like really crazy
so i think we should get into everything
because we have a lot to cover today so
without further a
do where are you he's busy busy cool
don't have him
booked and busy also doesn't want to
support us for 701 keep that in mind
will you happy 70 first episode you guys
yes we're going to put the balloons back
up for 702.
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and it should come as a surprise to
absolutely no one that today's episode
is brought to you by broche
the best electric toothbrush on the
market take it from me and the thousands
of toasters who have upgraded
their dental hygienic experience um and
i know we have some rdh toasters
registered dental hygienist so you gotta
get your hands on a brush the best
and most affordable electric toothbrush
on the market it comes with six unique
modes to customize your brushing
experience
it has a four week battery life a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
it also offers a very sleek design a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
that comes in trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter jackie and i have
been brushing
for over a year now and like i'm
stunning so if you want to be stunning
get your hands on a bruce and you can
get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit and
the refill plan
when you use promo code toast bruce dot
com that's 15
off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
love it thank you for that first story
big olympics news
oh b-o-n simone biles suddenly exits
women's team event but says she's okay
and will be back for other finals
in a surprise reversal of her tokyo
olympic hopes simone biles exited the
women's gymnastics team final early on
tuesday night in japan after briefly
leaving the competition floor following
a botched
showing on the vault her first event
gymnastics officials said it was
health-related but were not more
specific
speaking with reporters after the final
ended bile said she was quote okay
just dealing with some things internally
which will get fixed out in the next
couple of days
she said she planned to return for
thursday's all-around final
in a statement to people and other
outlets usa gymnastics said during the
event that quote simone has withdrawn
from the team
final competition due to a medical issue
she will be assessed daily to determine
medical clearance for future
competitions
biles the reigning olympic all-around
champion and five-time medalist
initially left the floor with the team's
medical trainer
following her vault routine in which she
bailed on her planned aminar vault for
an easier
one and a half twist and posted a 13.766
that is the lowest vault score of
viles's olympic career and event in
which she is dominated for years
until now soon after leaving biles
returned to the floor before the u.s
competed on the uneven bars she was seen
hugging her teammates
and as she remained on the side she was
dressed in her white team usa warm-up
gear
jordan chiles who was in reserve for
that event replaced her
okay like i know that there's a really
good support system like suny lee jordan
childs like i'm really not worried
um but i'm worried about simone i really
am and
honestly like i've just been watching a
lot of olympics i don't know if i've
been mentioning that
and we as a country are sticking it up
like every time i'm watching we're
losing and like our kind of saving grace
is like
it's fine like simone we'll win all of
our medals back simone's monster and of
course that's a lot of pressure to put
on a young woman but like
i i've definitely been a part of the
problem i'm not gonna lie
um and now it's like okay we don't have
someone like we stink
i feel like this might be like the first
olympics where we don't win i know
there's not like an official winner but
like whoever is the most modest whoever
has the most medals and like you know
you you said you watch a lot of events
and especially towards the end like the
big ones and it's like who's coming out
on top and there's just like a sort of
sense of
i guess it's literally day two so it's
not fair for me to say but like katie
ledecky lost to that australian girl
like
everyone is just like not winning gold
and yes silver's good
as i say like literally never moving a
day in my life but it's just not gold
yeah i agree i mean there was a quote
yesterday from simone that she felt like
she had the weight of the world on her
shoulder
she does and i can imagine that she does
you know this like goat title that she
holds like it must be so much pressure
especially when you're competing like on
indiv like it's not like when you're in
a team sport and you're in like
you have other people you can bounce off
of like well gymnastics is a team and an
individual but
when you do your individual thing you're
acting on your own
yes yes yes yes yes you know yes yes so
um unclear the exact reason why she left
they cited medical issues but that could
be physical
or mental right and i can imagine um
the mental weight of it all is a lot
like literally an entire country
the greatest in the world is like on
your back like no one will leave her
alone
yeah i just wonder i mean i wonder if it
is like this mental this pressure that
she's under that's like
you know really stymieing her
performance
i wonder maybe she can consult with
other athletes there are so many in the
village
what do people do in order to sort of
alleviate that pressure
i literally think the only person that
simone could actually speak to who would
understand what she's going through is
like michael phelps like
all these other athletes are so excited
to be there of course they don't feel
the pressure i think
of course there's pressure with any
competition but like the pressure that
she feels is so
like on a global level i think the only
person who could literally offer any
sort of insight is michael phelps and i
would really encourage her to knock
on his door or maybe he should knock on
her or just call him up because he's not
in um yes he is oh he's in tokyo
he is um in studio you know he's with
the people oh he's commenting
he's a swimming guy okay also i saw that
tony hawk was going to tokyo
ethan ethan was going to tokyo i don't
know why he's there maybe just to see
like his
own dreams you know or maybe skateboard
commentary realized by someone else
probably skateboard commentary and
of course i'm like happy for tony he
finally made it to the olympics in his
you know preferred
sport but it's like still the gymnastics
girls don't get to have their parents
there
like and imagine and i'm sure that also
i'm sure that also adds to this burden
of like where do you who do you turn to
you can't always go to a coach like
these are people who are invested in
your professional and your teammates
are technically competing against in a
lot of the i'm sure like
they all have each other and they
support each other but like no one's
gonna support you like your parents no
of course this is like
this is definitely a consequence of not
having a single person like in your
corner who's just like
there for you i thought the same exact
thing like i'm sure i know her and her
mom are so close like
if her mom was there i feel like she
would be 1 000 times better
she was just you know but i'm glad tony
hawk and ethan can go right i'm glad
tony's there ethan's there
michael's there yeah you know but also
the paralympians have to share
one aid for 33 people and then some
paralympians couldn't go
of course because they couldn't work
under those circumstances right
so it's just makes no sense one plus one
equals sock suck
well also i've been watching some um of
the more obscure sports and i have to
say here's
highlights and low lights surfing one of
the most boring things i've ever seen in
my life because that's a new addition
right
no no no i don't think so and i felt
really stupid because like i've
obviously never been to tokyo i was just
like
when i think of tokyo i think of like
bright lights and i'm like there's a
beach in tokyo like i felt really stupid
was it not it wasn't a simulation
no that's why i thought i'm like i
thought it was gonna be like a wave
runner they have at the water park but
also because like then different surfers
are getting different waves
well so that's what they were talking
about basically this girl caroline marks
who's like the best in american
surfing she got an eight yesterday which
is huge you go against one girl
and you sit in the ocean for 20 minutes
and you decide which ways to take you
get scored for each wave that you do
take whoever has the highest score at
the end
so this they actually serve for about
combined 45 seconds out of the 20
minutes you're just waiting for them
to decide which way to take but also if
the 20 minutes that you get don't give
you like great waves which they did not
get good waves but the girl from
i think it was south africa um really
just
was taking every wave that she could and
caroline marks was like waiting for the
best one and i'm like
girl it's never coming waiting for you
is like waiting for dr rain in the
stroud like
it was so boring but then this morning i
tuned in to handball
i don't know if that's the official
title but they were all running around
with a ball in their hand throwing
throwing it into a soccer net
rugby no rugby's football
rugby is like it looks like soccer but
they're holding the ball
they're holding the ball but it's on an
inside court handles when you do it
against the wall
huh okay but it's not rugby
rugby you play with the football right
like a shaped football
like a soccer ball you play outside no
yeah and it's very aggressive
no it was that was not what i'm telling
you it was handball but isn't handball
when you take your hand and you do it
against the wall
yeah like that's what we did in middle
school yeah i wonder what this sport is
called it was
fascinating it's like two like 12-person
teams against each other i was watching
france for spain
women's sickening then stayed up to like
i think it's
hand ball thank you thank you i'm so
athletic
um and ben stayed up to like three in
the morning watching women's basketball
because he's like in love with one of
these girls sue bird i'm like are you
gonna leave me for sue bird
um and they won that's so exciting how's
break dancing going have you seen
anything
didn't we report that like in addition
to skateboarding like breakdancing was
being added as a sport
gotta go for gold yeah and then i also
saw um
on the news up but it was like kind of
unmute so they're considering adding
gaming to the olympic games i saw that
new segment too and the guy was like
interviewing a gamer and he was like
what do you say to people who say gaming
is not a real sport
um and the guy was just like it is real
sport it should be part of the winter
olympics though because you do that you
know
honestly like in the cold is race car
driving
a olympic sport because i'm thinking
because i'm thinking like i don't know
if it can be considered olympic sport if
you're sitting
oh no what about rowing no growing yeah
yeah yeah
breakdancing is coming in 2024 so
everyone get excited for that i got a
kitchen training
yeah totally remember like when
everyone's flaxset batman's fuzz was
like
that thing you would like swoop your leg
around and like it would like get caught
on your hand
yeah yeah i wonder if i could see the
worm
you you used to worm never yeah you did
don't lie no i didn't
race car driving used to be an olympic
sport not anymore anymore
in the 1900s i wonder what happened
there maybe because like
it should be an olympic sport if no if
it's a professional sport gaming is
going to be a sport
yeah i don't want to offend the gamers
because i actually feel like they're
really scary but i just don't really
feel like it's
should be an olympics part yeah do they
consider themselves athletes
well i'm a podcaster so i think i'm an
athlete as well so podcasting will be
totally if gaming is a sport
athletically so is podcasting i get up
here every day
i'm like drenched in sweat yeah no you
get out of breath back in my knees you
need
water you're sore i need to get massaged
you have vaseline on my face
so i don't know if gaming really i don't
think that's fair i think it was up for
debate
and we're just a part of the debate i
also think the ioc international olympic
committee has lost their goddamn minds
like they're just making the worst
decision this year
i know especially like with koben and
they're really not taking care of the
athletes and i remember
like years ago where was that one in
russia
sochi sochi and like everyone was taking
pictures and videos
of like the olympic um the village it
was like not completely
hurt it was like condemned everyone was
like sleeping on the floor
and it was like funny hahaha i feel like
it's literally 10 times worse did you
see their beds this year
no they're made of cardboard oh no i
didn't see and they claim it's like for
sustainability
and like to help their backs but it's
like no that is so crazy i did see like
one of the dormitories because i was
following like emma coburn and it's just
like so crazy that like michael phelps
would sleep on that bed someone miles
like greatest of all time no wonder
she's having a hard time
like we just assume like they're at the
ritz like as they should you know
glamming up
and instead they're just like in a twin
bed with their teammates like in a
dormitory but there are a lot of really
um
good olympians who are creating so much
content on tick tock like really behind
the scenes like i got a whole tour of
the dining hall
because it has to be big enough to feed
10 000 athletes fascinating that is
fascinating yeah
cool well we're thinking of simone i
mean so this hasn't aired yet this airs
tonight in prime time but it happened
this morning at 6 45 a.m so we should
have said spoiler alert
because i think there are some people
who try to avoid like not saying that's
nuts what's going on
i was trying to do that i didn't know if
we were gonna like report on this today
because
it's a spoiler for prime time but now
you're briefed and now you should watch
yeah no i'm definitely gonna watch
tonight's tonight like i'm actually
really glad
like love island's not on tonight oh no
it is on it wasn't on last night what
i'm just like so overwhelmed like
it's i tried to scream but my head was
underwater
what's that a song from tiktok from
billy eilish
oh hold on sorry
oh god i tried to scream
but my head was under water
[Music]
got it i know the song now just the the
way you say it oh the triangle changed
it
the first time you sang it was just like
off pitch
a little it's okay rude are you ready
for our next story
which is a little interesting royal news
it's kind of like my favorite
when you ask like what's your favorite
news for me
it is iron mine's divorce news no
is interesting royal news the crown
turned down sarah ferguson's offer to be
a royal advisor for the show
she is so thirsty but she's the one
admitting that this happened
yeah of course she is because it got her
in the news she was also on friends she
was in town and country
giving them um giving them this intel
prince andrew's ex-wife sarah ferguson
offered to be a real-life royal advisor
for netflix hit the crown
but was turned down the 61 year old
duchess of york admitted to towning
country magazine
that she wrote to the show's executive
producer andy harry's to give insight
direct from the royal household
i said to him why can't i help my
character said fergie who still lives
with scandal scarred andrew despite
their split in 1992
i didn't know that wait her character in
the show has she been in the show yeah
like once she maybe that's why they
didn't want your input because nobody
cares about you no and also like if she
were to give input about her character
like she's obviously gonna be biased
frame it more favorably of course i
think next season will probably get more
sarah ferguson stuff and like scandal
with the feet on the beach you guys
remember
no but i know the scandal is that they
got divorced yeah yeah because she was
kind of like her feet played with it was
crazy
just crazy like i'm not even lying let's
i'm just going to google sarah ferguson
feet yeah um feed pics but i think it
would be hoove
maybe she's not like a reliance she's
not a reliable source she's so biased
yeah so here and i'm sure they have
plenty of royal accents
let me see her foot pics that guy's
kissing her foot
those pictures they were like paparazzi
pictures they were like it went viral
and then like you know oh here's another
picture up close of her v
um okay but so i think i like the
premise of you know a royal
family member offering their services to
the show but
i can understand why they turned him her
down
and i'm sure that netflix has like a
bevy of royal experts obviously not
anyone who's ever been as close to the
royal family as sarah ferguson
but again like she's had such a troubled
like
public life that i don't think she would
be a reliable source in any way
yeah because i think she would just use
it to try and like correct some
right some notions about herself right
and like make herself look great i can't
believe she still lives with andrew
that's disgusting one because it's weird
that they're divorced and two like
would you live with a pedophile i know i
wouldn't no i don't think that i would
no definitely not um so yeah really i'm
sure and i'm sure they have like royal
advisors people who probably know stuff
but to me when i hear the word like
royal advisor so and so was
blanks like secretary i just don't
believe it like but if you were like
you know beatrice is advising the crown
i'd say the crown is on point yeah i
think beatrice and eugenie would
actually be
very reliable sources for the modern
stuff if they ever get to it did you see
the new pictures of all the
all of um kitty spencer's different
wedding dresses no
her post so like you know british
weddings are weird they have like the
ceremony and then like later
like a dinner then like a party and then
after party her
like reception dress was sickening the
palace down like
my way it wasn't everything was dolce
and it was like
this off the shoulder and it was like
wipe it had these like gorgeous
flowers on the back train it was really
something to behold and
i just want to put it out there like how
jealous i am that i was not born kitty
spencer because like
i know of course you know no one's life
it's perfect and you never know what
goes on behind closed doors i just feel
like what goes on behind kitty spencer's
door is like still fabulous and perfect
you know
yeah i agree like how far off from her
instagram could it be
totally my instagram is very
with the exception of some facetune like
very close to who i actually am an
accurate depiction thank you
yeah yeah plus you do the show so did
you find the dress no she hadn't posted
it to her grade yet no i found it on
like some you know royal tick tock page
oh amazing can't wait to see that okay
next story
scott disick bails on an event after
asking a small town restaurant for a
private jet
this is like the saddest story i've
heard in years yep so
it seems that scott disick may finally
have lost his grip on reality entirely
says page six not me
for example the erstwhile keeping up
with the kardashians star appears to no
longer be able to recognize the
difference between a las vegas mega club
and the mid-sized upstate new york bar
and restaurant we're told disick was
booked to make a personal appearance
friday night at gaffney's in saratoga
springs
which is described by google as a quote
stalwart comfy eatery
with a garden patio and which serves an
onion ring tower for eleven dollars
yum and calls on thursday to ask if the
restaurant had a quote spare plane
that could come and pick him up from the
hamptons though the restaurant didn't
have an initial plane never mind the
spare plane
the gaffney's team gamely tried for the
first time in the history of the
establishment
to make her much to make arrangements
for a private jet to ferry a special
guest to the game they probably
literally
googled like private jet like what is he
doing meanwhile we're told disick's team
called again to say they found their own
ride to the spot after all and wouldn't
need the jet
but on friday the day of the event team
scott called once more saying they now
needed a helicopter
to bring him the 150 miles or so to the
sleepy town just north of albany
once again the gaffney's getting
ventured into the unfamiliar world of
how to rent a helicopter they ventured
into the unfamiliar world of private
aviation to try to get disciples to the
event
only to be told once more that disick
and co had made their own arrangements
but then his team called yet again to
say the chopper had fallen through
and that he wasn't going to make it to
the party we're told the restaurant had
to refund a slew of table reservations
that are sold on the back of district's
appearance
and bosses are now milling legal action
against disick to recoup the losses
to make matters worse the friday
appearance was supposed to be a makeup
event
after district had cancelled on them the
previous week reps for district did not
comment okay i have so many thoughts my
obviously the plain thing we'll get into
but my initial thought is like what is
he doing in saratoga springs
thank you like are times tough at
talentless why are you doing appearances
in random bars in upstate new york like
that's reserved for like people from
like the challenge you know not
keeping up with the kardashians like i'm
so
perplexed like that's what people like
who are on the bachelor five years ago
too like
what are you doing even accepting this
gig first of all yeah second of all
read the room of course they're not a
plane
a spare plane or a helicopter and like
justice for these people for being
accommodating rescheduling his event
trying to get him a plane trying to get
him a helicopter
i'm i'm upset i'm very upset
yeah i'm upset too this is a story that
like really doesn't look good for scott
and i'm gonna give him the benefit of
the doubt because i also
feel like this is the kind of story
where it's like it gets into the press
and it's like
not a representative like you know they
don't have the whole story no i feel
like i got a really full picture of what
happened
i mean this picture is very colorful
colorful
and clear and like i don't need to use
my imagination
but i could also i don't know i could
see how like this
is one of those like frustrating
celebrity stories where like
they don't understand because it doesn't
really add up that he's going to
gaffney's with the
onion rings right like maybe maybe like
someone like i don't understand why he
would accept this one he's also been
doing like he was at rush myers
in montauk which is like a really
popular place to go but like i don't
think they have a spare plane either
they definitely do first of all and
second of all the person who owns rush
meyers is scott's best friend
oh okay but so why is he doing all these
like local
small towns well because amelia has you
know
needs she's a woman she needs things and
he needs to provide them for her i don't
know if
you know being the daughter of a soap
star is really
raking it in for her but like he why is
he not at like tau las vegas
i don't know he obviously mistook
gaffney's for tao he obviously did
yeah he could make like a hundred grand
just flying to vegas
they fly him out and that's what he used
to do all the time right when he was
like in that toxic spiral of bad
behavior
on like you know courtney and chloe
taking my attention even when he's been
like sober and good like that is
like still good consistent work for him
that he was still doing i think it
became more challenging for him and he
had to
you know exert some willpower but like
that is before he had talentless like
that was his job like doing events like
that right and like getting kim to do it
and chloe to do it like making
commissions on those deals
for sure but like he wasn't trying to
send him to gaffney's maybe he was like
thinking that albany was the vegas of
the east i don't know like
i don't know because he was in the
hamptons like you said maybe he's trying
to like you know stay on the eastern
seaboard
he should have went to atlantic city
mohegan sun totally they sent a plane
for chloe
turning stuff no the place that um
foxwoods
foxwoods thank you so many there are so
many places
so many places i would love to have
scott and have planes
yeah i'm just confused onto like why
someone of scott's stature would accept
an appearance like that
right which makes no sense which is why
i i want to
give the benefit of the doubt i just i
really can't say there might be one more
piece to this story that we're missing
i stand with gaffney oh yes i mean
that's just a really crazy story
terrible are you ready for our next one
which is just some happy couple
beautiful wedding news issa rae marries
long time
beau louis diam in custom vera wang
dress
she said is so real and so special i
have to say
this is the week of iconic wedding looks
this is maybe the top
10 like celebrity royal not royal
celebrity wedding looks i've ever seen
like
she looks glorious she looks glorious
she married her long time
beau which we love to see at a
destination wedding she shared pictures
on instagram and she tagged the post
location
as saint john cap farat which is a
commune in the south of france
awesome stunning sickening gotta get
there's so much going on in the south of
france you know
jlo a-rod ben affleck yeah
it's array yeah gotta get there gotta
get a boat
and you're gonna get there if anyone has
a boat let me know yeah yeah
i could see us like on a boat i actually
could really use like a we gotta go on
below deck
oh yeah but they don't have below decks
south of france they have below deck
met is that mediterranean it's close
by ish that's like croatia right
yeah and then they also have greek isles
and caribbean caribbean however
but they also go to okay they're just
the two bucks
below decks are below deck med and then
the one in the caribbean in the winter
and sailing out but i don't know where
sailing out goes yeah no but i do think
below deck med like gets you in the
vicinity of where you're trying to be i
think so too
yeah and i think captain lee could find
his way like through
the islands to take me to central pay
yeah i think he could
i actually don't know if there's
anything i would consider like to doing
less than below deck it sounds
so tempting but i think the ultimate
a lot of people don't understand you
still have to pay for that charter trip
but it's significantly discounted i
think like for it's like a three or four
day charter you pay like 60 grand
yeah which i think if you're not on tv
and you're just chartering a regular
it's like a hundred grand
yeah we actually i think ben got an
email like one of us have received and i
think
brian got an email we were vlogging
because we were going to
askberry park askberry
asbury asberry park we were vlogging on
our way and i think ben received an
email about below
yes you're right if you want to go watch
one of our old vlogs we have all the
info in there
they're always looking for like
z-listers of what they offered it is
tempting it's really tempting i think
ultimately the the no though is like you
don't know how you're going to come off
and like
some guests have come off sometimes the
episode is not even about the guest so
it doesn't matter and those people get
lucky they just get to enjoy their trip
but a lot of the time the drama is about
the guests like being demanding drinking
too much like that'll be us like we'll
get off the boat go to a club like come
back vomiting everywhere like bringing
back strangers to party with us like
and i just don't know if that's what i
want to be known for in captain lee's
eyes
yeah or in like america's eyes yeah so
that's why it's a no from us totally and
of course you could say well i'll behave
well you know i
but then i went on a vacation when on a
yacht i can't predict how i'm going to
be
i'm not going to drink why are going on
vacation right what's the point in
spending all this money
no that's not a vacation totally are you
ready for our fifth and final story a
little
unhappy couple news oh no sammy
sweetheart
confirms her breakup with christian
biscardi it's actually really sad
it's over for sammy and fiance christian
more than a month after sparking breakup
rumors the firm new jersey star
confirmed
jersey shore stark the furniture jersey
the former jersey shore star confirmed
former jersey choreo
confirmed on tick-tock they cheated on
tick-tock yep that she and biscardi have
ended
their engagement go biscotti
sorry her video featured q a style
messages as she moved along to music the
messages
yeah it's this trend nope it's not nope
yes
bum bum no no jackie because look it's
like you haven't been on tickets
it says are you coming back to the
jersey shore no are you single
yes let me see are you happy yeah is she
doing this in the video she is but i
followed i think it's no it's a trend it
goes like this yes
um this is questions i constantly get as
someone who's met harry styles
do you think you're better than everyone
else yes just like a trend us one
directioners do i don't know if you
understand
you you just answered one question yeah
that's like the trend it's like kind of
like a satirical perspective
on this kind of colloquial trend if you
know what i mean
she did three questions no i know and
that's like that's the traditional trend
but i think
us tick talkers who offer a unique
perspective in a more
post-modern way um i'm trying to like
fit as many smart words as i know and i
don't know
attackers who just want to do less
than than the trends require
wow um
wow okay um
[Laughter]
so sammy sweetheart it's a single i'm
really not just like
obsessed it's fine it's fine
no it's just like imagine if i was like
you know something that's real like
you are constantly putting in no effort
into being bruno's mom like
see it's hurtful okay but you really
want to compare tick-tock to motherhood
yeah yeah uh my tick tock is my child
i nurture it it's such an integral part
of my career um
i just can't believe like you wouldn't
understand that you know yeah no i don't
understand
you're right i don't understand that my
sweetheart is single
and she also let you know she's not
coming back to jersey shorts in the past
it's been her relationships that have
kept her from family reunion but i also
think too much time has passed now
it's not her relationship actually i
mean if angelina can come back sammy can
come whenever
she wants i'm sure she will never come
back if ron's on the show and ron is
like a felon he's an animal like i don't
know how
the network hasn't like cut ties with
him yet he's such a monster i don't know
how they didn't cut ties with him
when he was being so [ __ ]
manipulative and gaslighting on the
original if you ever re-watch i've said
this before
if you ever re-watch jersey shore as an
adult you will be shocked at like what
we watched as kids
this is one of my dentist stories yes
you can stop laughing um
ron is literally so mentally and
verbally abusive to sam
it's like so disgusting he's so
manipulative and now like i understood
completely why she didn't come back to
the show
but now like ron really shouldn't be
there she should
yeah thank you for coming to her ted
talk
truly but she didn't want to be there so
then they were like okay ron will take
you
yeah of course because like you know the
more the merrier and like snooki left
but i heard she like came back
so much drama jersey super family
reunion oh there's a new i wonder if
anyone felt this way there's a new girl
on love island the one who knows shannon
she's literally smokey really like her
it's not even so much her looks the way
she talks and like her
facial movements oh that's funny yeah i
was curious if anyone else felt that way
i think her name was
genevieve but she goes by jenny cute no
i actually really don't like her
right because she's coming for shannon
yeah but she actually was like kind of
you know sparking up with jeremy
jeremy's still around yeah nice for him
it's shocking that he has like
he's so irrelevant but i think they're
all really good friends with him so like
every time there's like a ceremony they
like save him in jail yeah if like
there's someone who doesn't know who
they want to pick they're like
yeah and that's not being a good friend
that's on yeah no and that's what the
whole show was about friendship for real
it's true it's really true okay um those
were the past life stories i feel as
though you needed to know that the
truckers for jeremy have arrived
um all right so today is tuesday which
is our new day for deer toasters our
advice segment
where we'll give you our best possible
advice and sometimes it hurts but that's
just what we're here to do
um and if you ever want to write in the
email is dear toasters gmail.com we will
always keep it anonymous you can change
people's names
um but we're gonna do our best to help
all of our toasters and the deer toaster
segment is brought to you
by zip recruiter if you're a business
owner who's hiring you probably face a
lot of challenges when it comes to
finding the right person for your role
sometimes you can't find enough
applicants that have the right skill set
there's too many resumes to sort through
it can be
very overwhelming and you don't know
where to post your job so you can reach
the right people
and that's why hiring can feel like
trying to find a needle in haystack you
can post your job to a job board but
then all you can do is hope that the
right person comes along
and that's why you should try
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to
over a hundred top job sites with one
click then zip recruiters matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply
in fact zip recruiters so effective that
four out of five employers who post tons
of recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm me
with way too many options ziprecruiter
finds you what you're looking for the
needle in the haystack
and right now you can try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast again go to this link
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
all right dear toasters ready ready hey
jackie claudia hey
i need some beautiful stunning and smart
advice and i'm hoping you can help me so
let me get into it
yes get into it i've been seeing my
girlfriend let's call her evelyn for
almost a year now and we have a really
great relationship
with hugo oh my god yes it's
it's the first girl girl relationship
either of us oh my god yes another
girl's name is celia
i love a literal reference okay it's the
first girl girl relationship either of
us have ever been in so we are still
establishing our own dynamic
here's my issue she has a friend that
she talks about all the time
celia evelyn makes always makes comments
saying how much she
loves celia is obsessed with her thinks
she's such a catch
evelyn says that celia is the prettiest
of her friends and makes comments about
wishing they were roommates
basically jumping on any chance to talk
about her so it makes me feel like she
has a crush
celia isn't gay so nothing would ever
happen but it still makes me feel weird
i'm trying to decide whether i'm out of
bounds for feeling jealous when evelyn
makes those comments or if i'm right
in feeling jealous if this was my
boyfriend i'd shut it down immediately
but for some reason it feels different
having it come from a girlfriend
who i do know loves and wants to be with
me should i say something to evelyn or
ignore the comments because our
relationship is pretty solid otherwise
i don't want to come off as super needy
or insecure if i do bring it up i wish i
was that girl who was just so unbothered
and confident but in reality i'm feeling
like a little green monster of jealousy
over this
hoping up from hoping to get a
perspective that's not like other girls
perspectives
um and will help set me straight thanks
an unsure toaster that's tough
i think that my perspective is like
other girls because this would bother me
too well of course but like i don't know
the feeling of not wanting to be like
annoying and like clingy or like
weird is very legitimate so i think it's
just all
about how you communicate it right and i
don't even know if i would get to
saying something because i don't know
what there is to say there's nothing
that's
really been done that's wrong and at the
end of the day
celia is not gay so like it doesn't even
matter technically yeah but it's still
like
hurtful it's still hurtful i guess you
could just say
i guess you could mention it because
maybe sometimes like once someone says
something to you and like it's in your
mind
and you weren't aware of it before
you're gonna bother you forever you're
you're just so much more aware of it so
now if she knew that every time she
brought up celia it was like a little
bit of a sore subject
she would bring her a blessed probably
you know honestly this is kind of like
how i was feeling last night when ben
was like being obsessed with super like
right in front of my face
like i should have said something you
should have said something but that's
probably how he feels like all the time
about
maverick so true
[Laughter]
i'm so guilty of this you're right
tyler's saying
so okay i think you definitely have to
say something also it's just like that's
a
i don't think that's a good way to like
be in a relationship like if you're
feeling something say it
yeah and like honestly i think it's a
really reasonable thing to say so if she
thinks you're being crazy like she's
gaslighting you
yeah i if you're feeling something say
it because it's not just gonna go away
on its own
but maybe like hype yourself up listen
to that sara bareilles song but i also
say
what you want i don't agree with the
idea like if you're
every single feeling you have to you
have to speak out no
that is a fault of our generation like
every millennial and like zillennial
thinks like i have a feeling and i need
to be heard like no the world is not
here to listen to you
all the [ __ ] time no but i just feel
like if you have a feeling
over and over and over again and you
can't move past it like yeah maybe
maybe speak up but like just because you
feel something in one moment like
doesn't mean you need to share with
everyone
no like not every feeling has to get off
your chest like some things are okay to
stay in the chest sometimes you just
gotta bottle it up like a normal person
no totally like
i feel like we're just like spoiled as a
generation because we were conditioned
to like share our feelings and like go
to therapy and that really is great
but not like all the time yeah no there
is a limit
no and the limit does exist don't listen
to lindsay lohan okay
all right next up hi claudia and jackie
listening to the toast every day is the
highlight of my day and as a fellow dog
mom listening to the toast while walking
my dog it's truly the most relaxing part
of my day
a few weekends ago i took my best friend
rachel home to get out of the city and
go to the beach
she had always made little comments here
and there about my about thinking my
brother was cute and i never really
discouraged it my brother ross
was going to be there with his friends
as well on the first night we all went
to bars together and ross and rachel
were together all night holding hands
kissing and kept leaving the bar
together to go outside
i hated it the next day we had a
discussion about boundaries and i told
her that i really didn't like it
especially when they would mysteriously
leave together and not tell me
i told you i didn't really want to give
it any want it to go any further and i
wanted to keep
in the loop if she wants to be kept in
the loop if they went any further
the next night we all went out again and
when we got home ross and rachel
disappeared together for like an hour
i had no idea what was going on and i
felt like such a loser and was stuck
playing ping pong with ross's friends
sorry it's not nice laugh i was pissed
at her when she came back and joined us
especially because she offered no
explanation
flash forward a few days i called ross
to chat and check in i couldn't help
myself and asked him what happened
russ told me that they hooked up every
night of the trip she didn't tell me any
of that and i feel like trust has been
completely broken because she
specifically went against the boundaries
that i said
on top of that ross feels a little weird
about it because he was really drunk and
she wasn't
i told her that i need space for now and
i haven't spoken to her in like a week
and i don't know how i will ever trust
her again after she did that with my
brother and purposely kept it for me
however she has been my best friend for
three years and i miss her so much i
feel really lonely without her
but i don't know how i'll be able to
move on from this any and all advice
would be accepted
thank you and i love you oh this is
layered because this is layered i was
ready to be like
get over your sister and your your
brother and your friend be happy they
are clearly so
in love i agree but the last part was
really drunk and she wasn't
is weird like she took advantage of the
situation yes and the fact that
she was hooking up with the brother all
weekend so i was just feeling like oh
then they have like you know that's
gonna be a real thing
you tell your friend that you tell your
friend that yeah so i agree
in the beginning i was gonna be like
just get over it like i just hate girls
who are like weirdly in love with their
brothers you know but
that's not the vibe i'm sorry i
misjudged i really did like
there's something weird here and i know
you're lonely but
i feel like rachel needs to be cut out
she seems really [ __ ] toxic i think
that that is
maybe where this will end up but i think
there are some steps you could take
i would first confront her and like see
see how she tries to spin this you know
and be like
and just say exactly how you feel like
you hooked up with my brother not crazy
about it but also i'm more upset that
you didn't tell me
and the circumstances around the hook up
right we were like together
all weekend and like we're friends like
why don't you share if you woke up with
anyone else you would have told me
of course and then also i just want to
remind you like three years is not a
long time
um if you do happen to lose the
friendship you know well that's the
thing i was going to say i feel like in
friendships a lot of the time like
you're so invested in like the history
and the memories that you let people
like get away with things that
are like truly atrocious when so much
about life is like meeting new people
like join a toaster group like make new
friends like
i don't know not every friendship is
like worth hanging onto and this girl
sounds toxic as hell
yeah but i would give her enough benefit
of the doubt just to get her perspective
i mean there is a chance that the
brother is trying to downplay it to his
sister
saying like she was all over me right
right like i didn't do anything that's
true too
but then hooked up with her every single
night of the trip and but he felt weird
about it kept going
oh that's interesting makes you think is
rachel the victim here
that's why i'm saying you just need to
talk to people yeah communication
that's true every side of the story and
then put together
the version that you think happened
based on the facts at hand
that's really interesting all right
third and final jackson claude
i don't know if i'm acting like a crazy
five-year-old because i'm upset that my
friend is literally copying me but this
is very annoying ooh that is annoying
that is annoying i'm 28 years old my
friend is 22.
that's kind of weird like under what
circumstances these two meet like one
was in eighth grade and one was in the
second grade
like i'm just curious like how do you
meet as a 28 year old i guess like
none of my friends are 22. what
i should keep reading okay i'm 28 years
old my friend is 22.
we met because i'm a property manager
and she rented an apartment for me okay
we clicked
you know that is like a very kind of
toxic dynamic between a landlord and a
renter
and that's also like the beginning of a
horror story totally
we clicked and became very close after
your friendship she asked me to go to
their house in florida for vacation and
i was so excited oh i love a rich friend
with a vacation home
once i got there this is a horror movie
sorry yeah so this girl the older one is
28. yeah
the property manager the property
manager
so but she was the one who went to the
22 year olds floridian's house okay
once i got there the 22 year old was
copying literally everything i was
saying and doing for example i had my
nails done as i always do when everyone
kept commenting
so she had to book an appointment to get
them done she hates having her nails
done
they liked my sunglasses and flip-flops
so immediately she was looking up the
stores i got them at so she could
get them too i had airpod airpod pros
and i read a ton she has said a thousand
times that she hates reading
and she had to stop at the store to get
airpods and a book she heard my friend
and i say
heller to each other on the phone in
front of her friend who laughed it
who laughed and then every two seconds
for two weeks she would say hello
to everything i might sound crazy but it
was just too much ever since then i was
super sensitive to seeing exactly how
she was almost morphing into me
i was like i like her for her and i want
to be myself without having to be
i'm sorry i like her for her and i want
to be myself
without having to be friends with
another another version of myself how do
i tell someone to stop wearing army
pants and flip-flops just because i have
is it rude am i overreacting sincerely
very annoyed but sensitive to other
feelings toaster
well it's definitely weird behavior but
like so is hanging out with the 22 year
old and so that's what 22 year olds do
like they're not
fully formed and they're trying to form
themselves so they're like i'm going to
take bits and pieces of things i see in
the world that i like and add them to me
unfortunately she likes
all of you oh my god i have a thought
what i feel like
i feel like someone worth the same about
me you're 28
no no i'm the 22 year old okay because i
like okay oh my god wait i have a
consideration did you go to someone's
house in florida
well okay i think they maybe changed
some details because my best friend in
the world is brian kelly who's
like 10 years older than me okay i think
brian worth the same about you yeah let
me just
just bear with me here because okay
because
yes he's older than me okay and i always
go to his house
like i'm going this weekend and i
every time i leave his house like i talk
just like him and his friends because
like they have such a cool language and
like i'm just like always like copying
it like
you know i always say everything's like
turn and like it's twisted moronic
those are all brian's words like i
totally like every time i hang out then
i just like start to talk like him okay
and i feel like
jillian like who emailed us in is it
from someone named ryan
not brian okay i just want okay listen
because when i did the copy when you
hang out with people like you do start
to talk like that even if you listen to
this show you start to talk like that
that is normal the nails the books the
everything yeah the books is really
losing it's
it's the air pods it's too much and
that's what you get
maybe maybe it's like a metaphor like
brian started watching drag race and
like i started watching drag race
i just think it's not about me i don't
think it's about you unfortunately
unfortunately unfortunately okay no i
think this is what you get for hanging
out with a 22 year old when other 22
year olds hang out with each other
they're all figuring out the world
together they don't know exactly what
they like but when you're 28 which you
know what i actually i am 20 maybe i
wrote this in
you know it by the way you know yourself
so well better than you've ever known
yourself before i'm sure you know in
your 30s
you'll know even better but i i actually
do feel like i was realizing i was
having like a minute of realizing stuff
and i was realizing that like i really
know what i like
and like what makes me happy and like
things that i have like no time for
and so i think a 22 year old is kind of
inspired by that now i think this girl
is going about everything in the
complete wrong way and i also don't
think you need to
um work very hard to like protect a
friendship with a 22 year old like what
are you doing anyway but it's not like
you're lifelong friends like she's a
tenant
right so i mean i i don't know if it's
worth even saying something and also
when you do say something you sound
crazy also
keep in mind like imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery but i think
only when it's like being credited to
you i don't think you should say
anything one because like
technically she's not doing anything
wrong it's like weird and sweet in a way
yeah and so like if you don't want
people to hang out with people who are
annoying and immature don't hang out
with people six years younger than you
yeah
and it's not like six years like oh i'm
40. she's 46 because at some point
it all comes out in the wash but your
20s are such like a formative year like
there's such a big difference
between a twenty two and a half
different person from 22 to 28 and your
brain isn't fully formed until you're 25
so i would say
it's like sweet maybe in three years and
if it's really bothering you then stop
hanging out with 22 year olds because
you clearly don't like 22 year old
behaviors
yeah which i couldn't understand why you
wouldn't of course 22 year olds are
annoying
that would be annoying yeah like
especially if she's not like admitting
that she's copying you
right now like pretending like i just
have this original idea i want to go get
books in an airpods i think we all
really like to read any
tear pods totally like i think we all
need to go get our nails done
like it's losery for sure but you're you
really need to lower your expectations
yeah i agree but that's not weird that
it bothers you that would bother me no
of course it's bizarre but
it's also like it is a little flattering
yeah of course like i wish someone would
think i was cool enough to copy
everything i do nobody copies anything i
do
i copied your nails i guess it's like
the one thing i literally copy
everything you do i copied your shoes
look
oh yeah we're wearing the same shoes
today like i've waited a year because i
couldn't find them like i copy
everything everyone else does but i did
i copied your entire phone case look
literally
copied no but i copied your nails like
big time even though you made fun of me
and said that they didn't fit but
they don't fit like what do you guys
think jackie needs press-on nails for
children because her nails can't relate
are so skinny and thin
and those like literally the one that
you put on your thumb
i put on my pinky that's really funny
and they don't make one small enough for
your fingers but they are
uh filiable and you should file like if
i'm gonna be filing
i'll just file my nails like yeah i
guess filing sucks
the sound the sand um well that is your
toasters again if you ever want to write
in dear toasters at gmail.com is the
email to do that
and if you've written into us and you
have an update for how our advice went
and if it went over well if you took it
you didn't take it we won't be upset
email us an update at your toasters
gmail.com that is
our show our show no one else's 701
don't get it twisted
do not get twisted it's easy to get
twisted i'm constantly twisting 100
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium morning
show where we deliver the fafsa stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube's ever
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public video i
have video cast box all the places
so every listen podcast find us morning
to us leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
the society season two i think nails the
manicured nails the manicure nails
manicure instagram emoji emoji you know
the nails of the manicure
have a great day guys love you so much
bye bye
you